- [Jeremy] Thanks everyone
for getting started.
Hold on one moment, and we'll
begin in about 10 minutes.
- [Woman] Begin.
- Okay everyone, this is Jeremy Schifeling
with Khan Academy.
Thank you so much for your patience
getting started this
morning or this afternoon,
depending on where you're calling in from.
It is my extreme privilege to
introduce you to Conor Corey.
He's one of the most awesome teachers
that I've met in a long, long time,
and just someone that I wish
was teaching my own kids
because of the incredible way
that he goes about
engaging his own students.
So Conor, thank you so much
for being with us today,
and thank you for sharing your expertise
with the larger Khan Academy community.
- [Conor] Thank you, it's
been great to be here.
It's been a pleasure to be invited in.
- Absolutely, let me see
if I can get your webcam set up here.
Just go ahead and turn that on if you can.
All right, we're in business.
- All right.
- So again,
thank you everyone, for
making time out of the day.
I know, this is week two for many of us
as far as kids running around
while we're trying to serve our students.
Conor's in the same boat.
You have four kids, is that right, Conor?
- I do, and they are all at home.
My wife is distracting them
in the other room right now,
and so if you hear
screaming in the background,
that's coming from me.
- Well there you go.
That's the secret to being a great teacher
is having a very supportive spouse,
so thank you to her, and
thank you to your kids
for letting us steal you
away for about half an hour.
But I promise to make it super worthwhile
for everyone on the line,
and so I wanna start with a little bit
of your background as an educator.
Tell us a little bit about
how long you've been teaching,
what you've been teaching,
the students that you serve,
and then we'll go from there.
- This is my 17th year of teaching.
I spent the first 13 years of my career
teaching in the Philadelphia
School District public schools.
We were on a contract issue.
For a few years, I went back to school
to go into administration,
and that's kind of really
where I found my love
for curriculum and math,
more than administration.
I, around my 14th year,
I took a job as a math interventionist,
which was kind of a new position
in Centennial School District,
but it was one that I thought was needed.
It was more of, every school
has reading specialists
most of the time,
where students are pulled out
to rebuild a foundation for literacy,
but that foundation for
math is sometimes skipped
as they go grade to grade,
so I was, for three years, I spent,
pulling students for
small group instruction
to rebuild their mathematical foundation,
and then this year, I went
back into the classroom
to teach middle school math,
which is a passion, obviously.
So I am back as a sixth grade
math teacher this years.
- That's awesome, and tell us a little bit
about how you've been using Khan Academy.
- I've used Khan Academy
for about 10 years now.
I think it came out of a
need more than anything.
While in Philadelphia, as most large,
metropolitan school districts,
we're a little bit underfunded,
and some of the materials that we needed
were not available.
The class set of books was of 20,
but I had 34 students,
and they were kind of 10 years old.
So you had numerous wonderful pictures
drawn in by fifth
graders over the 10 years
that resembled me sometimes.
But, so we had to find a way.
Also, most of my students
weren't on level.
They were two years below level,
maybe some are a little bit advanced,
but getting that material
became red tape paperwork of,
well, maybe you have to fill this out
because we're gonna see if
they're special education,
and it's, no, they're not special ed.,
they're just a little behind in fractions.
I just need the material.
Kahn Academy kind of
gave me that for free,
and I was able to implement
almost a centers-based approach
like many literacy teachers already do
at the elementary level.
We kind of rotate our
class each day in that way,
where I may teach one group of 10 students
on a third grade level if
we're all working on geometry,
and then they'll rotate,
they'll work on Kahn Academy,
and then a project in the third station
that has to do with geometry,
but then the next group,
it may be four grade,
and fifth grade after that,
and kind of try to hit
their academic level overall
for each of them.
We may not get to the third grade student
on a third level to a sixth
grade level that year,
but we will rebuild the foundation
so the vocabulary makes more sense
and they can strive further
rather than just kind of skipping along
and hope they pick it up.
- Very cool, so build those foundations
kind of like Tim Vandenberg
has been talking about in
his Mastery Learning Webinar.
- Yes, and Tim, I share the same belief
as Tim most of the time.
We did many things of
going back to kindergarten
and starting all the way over,
and it's doing fantastic.
- Very cool, and so, in the
sense of the academic side,
I think one of the
things that any follower
of your Twitter feed,
which I shared in the chat a second ago,
will notice is you really bring this joy
and this love of learning
to everything you do in the classroom
in normal times, in the best of times.
What are some of your most successful
engagement techniques for
really getting your kids
excited about Kahn Academy,
and more importantly,
just learning itself?
- I came to the belief a long time ago
that all kids, it doesn't
matter your background
or where you're from,
they enjoy kind of
embarrassing their teacher,
seeing their teacher look like an idiot,
doing things that they would not normally
be able to do in a school building,
and I figured attaching memories
like that to my classroom
was always the best way.
I think it came about like,
it came out 10 years ago,
there before all the Fortnite dances
and everything like that.
There was a dance called the Wu-Tang
that all my students
would just not stop doing,
and in the schoolyard, if you
looked down at the schoolyard,
there's 200 kids in a circle dancing,
and one kid, he just walked by
and he sharpened his pencil
and he started dancing,
and I was just kiddin'
around and made fun of him,
I'm like, "That's it, that's all you got?
"You better practice before
you go out to the schoolyard."
He started side, talkin'
trash, he was like,
"You can't do it."
I'm like, "You were born in 2004.
"You don't know anything about Wu-Tang."
I'm like, "I got it."
Then they all wanted to see it,
and it was, "Okay, if you all get to 20%,
"I'll go out in the schoolyard and do it,"
and they loved it.
They worked so hard those
next two weeks or so,
and then it kind of spiraled from there.
A kid had a water balloon
in their desk one day and I,
the many reasons you wouldn't think
a kid would have a water
balloon in his desk,
you almost had to stop and go,
what possessed you to
think this is a good idea?
Then we started talkin' about,
"I'll let you throw water balloons at me
"if you guys get to 30%."
Those kind of memories, we
just started doin' crazy stuff,
and I've worked with unbelievable staff
over the years that join in,
and we just try to get things
that they can't purchase,
like certificates,
but more of memories that they wanna do.
- That's cool, and so
what kinds of results
have you gotten with this approach,
like making yourself say,
"I'll do whatever it takes
to get you to mastery?"
- I think you hit almost
every angle of your students.
You have the introverted students
who may not wanna say they wanna study it,
and you have some of the,
your most extroverted students
that are the ones screaming
and always doing stuff.
You're getting all of them
to work for a similar goal,
which is to embarrass you,
or even the other staff members.
We did one, you wouldn't believe.
When I was at Willow Dale for three years,
I had an unbelievable staff,
and one time we did a wheel,
it was called The Wheel of Doom,
and we put all the teachers names on it,
and they basically, whoever won LearnStorm
for that month, whoever
had the highest growth,
that class came up, we made an assembly.
I had 16 teachers come up front
and sit there in chairs,
and they would spin this wheel,
and it would land on
ketchup, mustard, mayonaise,
and they would just get to
squirt it in the teacher's face,
and they had a blast
while 400 kids are in the audience
screaming and excited about
math work they're doing.
So I think it was, things like that
just engage students more,
and whether they, the
learning comes secondary.
It will always come
as long as they're
excited about something.
- I love that.
So obviously, those are the best of times,
being their physically
for The Wheel of Doom.
We are far from the
best of times right now
as we chat, unfortunately.
What are you doing with
your students today
to drive engagement in this
remote learning environment?
What would you recommend from
that toolbox of best practices
for everyone else listening right now?
- I mean, I'm going, I'm attempting,
always trying new things.
I'm attempting to do similar things
with just getting the students excited.
I think a lot of teachers
are starting to run into
federal guidelines of online learning,
I think that's becoming a struggle,
but I've used Flipgrid throughout the year
to communicate, and now we're
using kind of Zoom meetings
to see, just to get in
touch with your students
and do things, not work that's required,
but voluntary for something to do.
Your students miss you, they do.
I miss them, and right now,
we're doing a TikTok challenge
because I know that's everything
my students are into right now,
so I put out a few
assignments on Kahn Academy,
I said it's voluntary.
If you would like to join in, tell me,
and I put them in a class,
and I put five assignments
up for the week.
If they finish those assignments,
my daughter and I will do
the Flip the Switch Challenge
for TikTok, and then it
to them through Flipgrip,
or send it to 'em through Zoom
or something like that.
But just to keep them engaged.
I send riddle, math riddles
to them through there,
just to kind of get 'em through the, it's,
everything's okay, everything
didn't totally stop.
Because I think a lot of
kids are scared right now.
They're looking at adults for answers,
and we don't have.
So we're just tryin' to, I think,
all get through this together.
- That's cool, so even though
it does feel like the
world is topsy-turvy,
you're still the same Mr. Corey,
you're still providing that same level
of excitement and motivation,
even if you can't be with them in person.
- We're hopin' to.
We're gonna actually try to get
some of the parents involved next week
and see if they will
participate in the same things
since they're at home with them,
and maybe have kids,
I think we were gonna
do a five refrigerate,
five thing blender,
so five things you can put in a blender
and that parent has to drink it.
Try to get the kids involved
and the parents involved
for something fun to do.
But, it's not new learning going on,
but we can all use the review,
and we just need maybe a
couple of laughs throughout it.
- Yeah, and that's actually
an interesting question.
So I think a lot of educators right now
are tryin' to figure
out, do I take this time
as if it's normal school
time, quote unquote,
and try to push forward with my content,
or do I go into that review mode
and just sort of keep them
stabilizing those foundations,
filling those gaps rather
than pushing forward.
Any thoughts on that sort of conundrum?
- I always think right
now is a review time.
I'm looking at it as, yes,
I'm teaching sixth grade students,
but they can all review
fourth grade content,
things they enjoy doing
or something maybe they
liked from years in the past.
Many times, like in literacy,
if a child's constantly reading,
you don't care if the
book they're reading,
that they're interested
in, is below level.
But for math, there's
always this different,
we have to push them and
push them on grade level
and never skip a beat.
I think this is more of a,
let's try to have some fun.
We don't wanna, most parents do not know
what slope intercept form is,
or how to graph systems of equations,
so if you're applying that
but you're not able to teach it,
and you're assigning those things,
it becomes a struggle for parents,
and I think that's kind
of the opposite effect
as they're already stressed out enough.
- Cool, well I love some of the things
you've already shared and answered
some of the most common
questions we've received.
So teachers were asking about,
how do you get students working
at the appropriate level for their need,
and you were talking about even going back
a couple of grades
if that's where the gaps are.
You can do that with Kahn Academy.
Okay, 'cause you were asking about,
how do you form a virtual
sense of community,
and it sounds like you're that
by getting all the students
working towards a common goal,
using a platform like Flipgrid
to engage not just the students
but their parents as well
in a really visual and exciting way.
What about this question, though.
One of the teachers asked,
how can I get kids who don't
even engage face to face,
even in those best of times,
to actually engage online,
when things are way harder?
- I mean, knowing your students
is always one of the largest
things you have to learn
in the beginning of the year.
I am always surprised at how
some of my introverted students,
or some of my students that don't engage
and raise their hand and answer questions,
how well online tools have worked
to let me know they're understanding
without them telling me,
to gaining perspective of
if they're getting a concept
that I'm teaching.
Kahn Academy has always done that
with the assignments
and watching them grow
where they don't have to be,
you know, maybe they're a little bit shy
and they don't wanna be the
one that asks that question,
that they don't know what this word means.
But when you see that they're
not achieving on something
that you know they understand,
it can be as simple as just
going over next to them
and asking them, "Well,
what's wrong here,"
and they're like, "I don't know
"what the word denominator means,"
and that's a simple fix,
but overall, to engage them,
it's, you see things like Flipgrid,
kids love making videos,
and I have one student who is very shy,
does not talk a lot.
I mean, he has friends, he
talks to the other kids,
but won't engage me very much in class.
Once we started using Flipgrid,
his whole persona changed
when I saw his first video.
He was Mr. Stash and he
was all very outgoing
and this and that, and
all the other kids saw it
and they started wanting
to be in his group
to make the next video.
Now he runs Mr. Stash Productions.
But he's still that same kid in class
that won't raise his hand,
that won't put himself out there,
but as soon as he is able
to make these videos.
So I found it has an almost
opposite effect at times.
- Interesting, so maybe that's
almost the silver lining
of the times we find ourselves in,
is because it's not all real time,
and it's not all live in the classroom,
those students who need
a little bit more time
on their own to process and sort of
share what they wanna communicate
now have that time in this
asynchronous learning,
whether it's creating a Flipgrid video,
responding to a Khan
assignment on your own time.
Students have that space it sounds like.
- Yeah, and I think that's always been
a significant advantage with Kahn Academy
that they have the time to
do the assignments again,
to try it one more time,
to stop and take a hint,
or to stop and watch a video.
The whole class isn't waiting for you
if you're not getting a concept,
or you're not moving on
with nothing else to do.
There's always something
that's right at your level
that you can kind of take time
to reflect and think about.
- Very cool, and so a
couple final questions
and then we'll open it
up for live questions
from the audience.
How can I help students
persist when times are tough?
You know, we've talked a
lot about growth mindset
and about grit in the last couple years.
Especially in this moment of crisis,
how do we help students get through this?
- I mean, I think it's important
to realize that we are all
going through something right now.
This isn't just going to affect
small parts of our country or our world.
I think you're just really
reaching out to your students,
whether it's through a Zoom meeting
or just letting them know
that you're still there
is so hugely important,
because some, everyone
thinks everybody's at home,
but many parents are
still reporting to work,
and some of our medical staff
and everything are at work
large amounts of the day,
and children are still at home,
by themselves, looking for something.
I think it's important to help
lead your families and your,
as a teacher, in those ways.
It's gonna be tough, but I think
just keeping at open line of communication
is the number one thing
that we can do as educators right now,
and allow students to ask questions,
and allow them to try to persist.
But obviously, with growth mindset,
we've taught that throughout the year
and continuing to do that,
but also using a lot of review concepts
that are just keeping them going
rather than struggling on their own.
- That's cool, that's so powerful.
I have to give a shout-out
Mrs. Andreessen in South Dakota
who sent me a video she created
for her fifth grade class this morning,
and she just said the simple words,
"I'm thinkin' about you."
I know from my own daughter's
experience, if you hear that
from the most meaningful
educator in your life,
that's powerful, even
when times are tough.
So just keepin' that line
of communication open
is so huge.
Then one last question that
came up quite a bit was,
okay, again, we're talkin' about students
who are all sort of
facing major challenges.
Some are facing even
bigger ones on top of that.
If you wanna support your
special education students
in the middle of this crisis,
any words of wisdom for
how to serve that audience
really, really well?
- I think this is an issue
that many educators are
facing at the moment,
and it obviously depends on a child's IEP
and some of the federal laws
that are coming into play
with districts trying to
go to virtual learning
for the next month,
and if they're abiding
by all of these laws.
For myself and my own experience,
I have students in my class with IEPs,
I always have my entire career.
I never really change what I'm doing
for one specific kid.
I change the way I interact
with certain students
and the materials I give certain students
and the way they can kind of participate
and how I can highlight them here.
But many of my students that have an IEP,
they are perfectly
producing, in math class,
they are participating, they're,
I kind of just always,
like I would do anything else,
I value the student, I know who they are,
and I know what kind of pushes them,
and I try to get into it that way,
but right now, with students
that do have an IEP,
I think there's, districts want teachers
to be extremely careful,
not requiring any work for
almost any of their students
as a grade until we kind of
get some of this figured out.
I mean obviously, we wanna make sure
we're hitting all our students,
but I think our teachers are doing that.
I don't know that our teachers
are looking and saying,
Well, I can only teach to this group,
and I can't teach to my other students
that may have a learning disability.
I think we're just all in it together,
trying to figure out how
we can engage everybody
and keep an online classroom going.
- Great advice.
So let me open it up to
questions from the audience here.
We've got a bunch coming in.
I wanna start with a
great one from Lindsay.
So Lindsay says, "Conor,
this has been awesome,
"but what kind of goals or targets
"do you set for your students?
"Do you focus them on mastering a skill,
"getting to grade level?
"How do you keep them from
just grinding toward a goal
"and actually feeling
a sense of progress?"
- I have used personalized goal-setting
for now seven years with my students.
I believe it's the most effective way,
and we celebrate that goal-setting
throughout the process.
So I have students that are
three years of different levels.
So what they would all,
they have these little Lego guys that,
you know, for mastery on Kahn Academy,
well, we print those out,
and the kids write their name on them,
and their goal may say,
"I wanna get to 45% in third grade."
I sit with that kid and I put it,
I hang it up on the wall,
and the next student maybe,
"I want you to get to 60% on fifth grade."
It's usually about 15% higher
than wherever they are,
but for the one to move on is fifth grade,
it's gonna take the same amount of effort
for the third, the student
who's on a third grade level
to move his score.
So we really focus these goals
on the child's current academic level,
and how much effort it
would take them to move up.
The majority of time, those goals
are not on grade level.
They are a little bit below,
some are a little bit above,
but any time a child hits a goal,
we usually have something,
and if you don't have anything,
kids love like, okay, you can take
whatever's in my desk that
you find that you want.
But you'd be surprised the
crap that's in your desk,
and the things that a kid will take.
It'll be a watch that was
on the floor two years ago,
it will be stickers for kindergarten
that you're like, "Yeah, I
shouldn't throw these out,"
and you just threw them in your desk.
They'll go through your desk
and they think it's
the coolest thing ever.
We did these, we have
these little bracelets.
I've been doin' these for years, they're,
you can buy hundreds of them for $20,
and they just, they start
to collect different ones
every time they set a goal,
but it's small goals
over and over and over
to eventually get towards mastery.
But I think setting grade level mastery
for all of your students
is just, it's unrealistic,
and there's no need to set
unrealistic goals for your kids,
'cause they're not gonna
be able to succeed,
so what's really the point?
If you know them, give
them the proper level,
let them hit small steps along the way,
and they start develop
that growth mindset,
and the kids don't really care
what level they're learning on.
- Yeah, I love how much of your advice
is just rooted in knowing your students.
If you know they're gonna be motivated
by something that's tangible, attainable,
then give them that.
Don't try to sort of
set the bar way too high
and intimidate them.
Make them feel good about their progress
and they'll wanna do it again.
So many questions are
coming in about Flipgrid.
They're saying, "What is this Flipgrid,
"what is it all about?"
Can you explain a little
bit more there, Conor?
- I started, Flipgrid's an unbelievable,
it's a free resource,
I started to use it heavily this year.
I began last year but it
was the end of the year,
a new platform, I'm like,
okay, maybe next year.
I started it.
Basically, you create
a video for yourself.
Yeah, there's the front.
You create a video for
yourself and for your students,
and they are, it's almost
like its own social media.
That video will go out to your students.
Your students are now able
to respond to that video,
and you could just do a topic such as,
"Hey, I just wanted to say hi to you guys,
"I want everyone to say hello back,
"see what you're missing about school,"
and there is things to
help all along the way
to get you started.
But we've used it heavily for
our explaining math this year,
where we have students create videos
on a mathematical topic,
of order of operations.
Okay, what do we do first?
They'll make different
scenes and different movies.
Around Christmas we did,
what does it mean to
have something 20% off?
Kids were making their backgrounds
of being in a store or paying
for something that's 20% off,
but they were able to explain to me
what those concepts were about
and what, how they
apply in the real world.
That gave me more than any
test could ever give me.
It showed me, wow, they're
actually understanding
each part of this process.
I think, and you're able
to respond to their videos,
the other kids in the class leave
what's called a Vibe,
and they're able to respond.
So it forms a sense of community,
and then you kind of have,
we have a mixed tape that
has all our top videos
from all three classes, the best ones.
The kids, I mean, we vote on the videos,
who came up with the most creative,
but it's an unbelievable program,
and it's 100% free.
I would suggest they check it out.
Like everything, just kind of start small.
See if you can get things started
with Kahn Academy, start small.
Think of all these platforms
for educators and parents,
it's kind of like when
you get a new phone.
You get it and you're like,
I just wanna send a funny
picture to my friend,
I don't need to sign up my Google Cloud,
I just, and you're
trying to figure it out.
But then day after day,
little bit after a little bit,
it starts to make sense and become easier,
and then you start to see the value
of all the things you
actually have on your phone.
I think if we start technology that way
in this online learning platform
that's going to continue
for the next few weeks,
I think that's our best option.
- Very cool, and then
Denise has a question,
which is basically, you
mentioned the federal regulations
and federal advice that
was just coming down.
Can you talk a little bit more about that
for educators who have not heard about
what's being shared at
that national level?
- At national level, you
have faith laws that are,
basically, you have to
ensure that every child
has the same access to education.
If you're trying to do online learning,
there are students that maybe don't have
the internet at home,
or maybe they don't have a device.
The only device they
have is a parent's phone
that's going to work.
So I think by districts pushing out
a platform of we're gonna continue school
without addressing those needs first,
and all the needs that
are in that child's IEP
of differentiated
learning, having an aide,
having someone else to explain,
I think we have a lot of issues
where districts are nervous.
Are they providing for every child?
That always is the number one thing.
You can't exclude a
certain amount of children
because it's not convenient right now.
So there's a lot of, I guess,
federal laws are put in
place for a good reason,
and now, in this unprecedented time,
people are like, I don't know
if I can get around this,
because am I then not
educating every child?
Am I providing what's been stated by law
that I have to do to educate this person?
But I think the lack of devices
and the lack of internet access
and different things is a big issue
that many people are seeing.
- Great, I'm gonna throw
down the gauntlet for you
a little bit, Conor,
I'm gonna stretch your
engagement abilities.
Some high school teachers
have been saying,
"This is awesome, but
awesome for middle schoolers,
"awesome for elementary students.
"I've got 11th and 12th graders,
"how am I'm gonna keep them engaged
"when they're already so
cynical to begin with,
"and on top of that,
"they have so much else on
their shoulders these days?"
- Middle school students
are just as cynical.
I think high school kids are just like
the older middle school kids,
they think they're too
cool for everything.
They think, they're just kind
of going through the motions,
but they're worried about
what they look like,
what this person thinks,
what's going on on social media.
They would find it just
as funny, and it does,
if you did stupid things
in your class with them,
if you did a TikTok dance
with your whole class,
if you did certain things
that they're interested in
that you find ridiculous,
but to them it's like,
all right, well, I have two things,
I have two classes I have homework for,
which one am I'm gonna do it for?
'Cause I'm not gonna
do it for both of 'em.
So you wanna be the teacher
that they'll do your homework for you,
they'll do, go the extra step for you.
I think again, it's knowing your students.
You may have one class that
you can do one thing with,
and you may have another
class that you can't.
But it's always, just always be willing
to try new things and
not embarrass yourself.
Nothing's gonna change if you
continually stay the same.
So if you're uncomfortable
in what you're doing all the time,
I think that's a positive thing.
- Yeah, and I'll just
throw out a couple ideas
that I've heard recently
for the high school set.
I know in a lot of ways,
they face the sort of
most daunting challenges,
because so much of their expected life
over the next few months is on hold now,
whether it's taking the
SAT, taking the APs,
graduation, college decisions,
all of this stuff is
supposed to be happening,
and now it's frozen.
What could you do to fill that void?
Could you host their virtual prom?
Could you take a page
out of ESPN's playbook?
ESPN is doing these senior nights
every night on SportsCenter,
shouting out the high school seniors
who would have been
getting vetted otherwise.
Could you sort of give it a chance
and really let your seniors shine,
even during this really difficult moment?
So if there's some way you can bring
that sense of normalcy,
that sense of tradition
into this virtual world,
I think you'll be a
superstar in their eyes,
no matter how cynical they are.
Okay, so let's see here.
I think we have time for
maybe one or two questions,
and so I think the biggest question
that I've gotten from a lot
of teachers at this point
is how do you ultimately serve students
at different levels,
given that everything
we've been talking about
in terms of Zoom or whatever,
feels like it's like, okay, one teacher
and all the students in a
big lecture environment.
How do you continue to
sort of differentiate
and make sure each student feels heard
and respected in this time?
- I think for the leveling, for myself,
I know most of my students' level.
I know where I'm kind of teaching them
and whatever topic it is,
maybe I assign to my
one group of 10 students
the remediative foundational skills,
and my higher group, maybe
the intense word problems.
But those skills all count
towards the same thing,
as our overall goal of
this stupid TikTok video
I'm gonna create, probably today.
But having that, knowing your students,
and having them all, each
doing different things,
you're also able, like
I said, with Flipgrid,
give them a chance to ask questions.
If you're in a virtual classroom with Zoom
and you're saying, "Okay,
submit your questions here,"
and then you can send that video out
just to the students that maybe need
a little bit of assistance with that.
But I think it's important
to try to recognize
all your students, too,
that are working at home,
that are putting in the extra effort.
But really just constant communication
is gonna be your number one thing
to see how kids are doing,
to see why, maybe, these 10, 15 kids
haven't logged on yet,
or haven't done anything.
Is there an issue?
'Cause maybe there is.
As teachers, we're
always looking for that,
to see how we can help in that anyway.
- Cool, well I think if
anyone wants inspiration
as we sign off here, I
would strongly encourage you
to check out Conor's Twitter feed.
He's at twitter.com/ccorey223,
and as you can see here,
he's got lots of examples
of engaging his students,
engaging his own kids at home
with cool crafts and activities,
and just gives you a
sense of what's possible
with getting students really
excited about learning,
even in this difficult environment
we find ourselves in.
So definitely follow Conor
and check out his ideas,
and keep your questions coming.
I know we didn't get a
chance to get to everyone.
We'll definitely be doing
more sessions like this.
So if you have other ideas
or questions for Conor
or for Kahn Academy,
please submit those in the
survey that will follow.
That being said, any last words of wisdom
for the audience, Conor?
- No, I wanna say thank you for tuning in,
and thank you over at Kahn Academy.
In the next few weeks, just
enjoy the time with your family.
You're not gonna be stuck with them
this large of a period for many years.
I would say just try not to
get on each other's nerves.
My wife asked me if I had to
chew like that the other day,
so I think we've been in
closed quarters for a whole.
But just try to enjoy the time.
I don't know we're gonna get it back,
and the more questions you
ask about what's gonna happen
next year with education,
the more, the less
answers you're gonna get.
So kind of focus on your family,
focus on your loved ones now
and what we can do together.
- Cool, well, I can't think of a better
message to end on than that one,
so thank you all for making
time out of your days,
thank you to Conor for sharing
your incredible expertise,
and here's wishing you
all a wonderful week.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.